Ah, the great British banger.
Or the lovely salami.
Or the battered saveloy.
Hang on, just what is a sausage?
And why do they taste so good?
The concept of sausages
goes back to antiquity -
stuffing animal guts with a meat,
fish or sweet batter mixture
was an obvious and practical way
to make easily cooked,
transportable food.
Originally, they were seen
as small puddings –
a large pudding was a haggis,
done in a stomach,
rather than a length of gut -
and, like puddings, they were
often boiled rather than fried.
The French word for sausage, boudin,
even gave us British
the word ‘pudding’,
since early puddings were sausages,
and sausages really were
a type of pudding.
Sometimes they were smoked
or air dried to keep through winter.
Everywhere, though,
for those who could afford it,
a spiced fresh meat sausage
was a pretty staple item.
Even for those who couldn’t afford
good meat and fine spice,
sausages were about
from very early on.
There was a play called The Sausage
Seller written in the 5th Century BC,
and already then the
lower-grade sausage
had a whiff of uncertain meat
disguised with judicious
sauce about it.
In the medieval era, northern,
wetter climes such as the UK
developed a speciality
in fresh meat sausages,
to be cooked before eating.
Elsewhere, in dry climates
such as the Mediterranean
which had good, stiff
breezes and mountains,
dried or smoked sausages
were more popular.
There they would cure properly,
and not simply go green
as they would in Britain.
There were still mixtures
with fish, fruit and blood –
black pudding for example –
but as the centuries rolled on,
most European sausages
became based on a mixture
of pork, pork fat and flavourings.
They were not posh,
and by the 18th Century
they rarely appeared at the
dinner tables of the wealthy -
though they happily ate them
as suppers and snacks.
But they were very popular,
and available for almost
every possible budget.
Mass production became possible
by the mid-Victorian times,
and even cheaper sausages came out,
with a hefty filler of bread or rusk.
Saveloys in particular
gained a reputation
for being based
on off-cuts and filler,
or indeed, horsemeat and sawdust
in some people’s view.
Then, as now, the dirt-cheap versions
rubbed shoulders with
the more expensive ones –
until the First World War,
when meat shortages meant that no-one
got much meat in their casings.
One theory as to why
they became known as bangers,
shortly after the war,
is that the level of filler meant
they banged and popped when fried.
However, it’s just as likely
to come from their shape,
which resembled shell casings,
not least as they were still
often boiled to cook them.
Normally, they are cylindrical,
but they can, on occasion,
be square like a Lorne.
Today, eighty-five percent of Brits
regularly consume sausages,
plain, as bangers and mash
or as in toad-in-the-hole –
though globally it’s the cocktail
sausage which is the king,
for a bite-sized piece
of porky glory.
Small or large, contents as you wish,
we’ve had sausages
for thousands of years,
and they are clearly here to stay.